Ladies and gentlemen, Aziz Ansari. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Last year, I was asked a host in event in Washington DC with a comedian Aziz Ansari. You might know him as Tom Havifert from Parks and Recreation or you might be binge watching his original series on Netflix, Master of None. What you might not know is that Aziz is also interested in human behavior. He's thought about how social norms have changed the way people get together, he studied
女士们先生们，阿齐兹·安萨里。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。去年，我应邀在华盛顿特区主持了一场活动，嘉宾是喜剧演员阿齐兹·安萨里。你可能在《公园与游憩》中认识扮演汤姆·哈维弗的他，或者你一直在Netflix上疯狂追看他的原创剧集《无为大师》。你可能不知道的是，阿齐兹对人类行为也十分感兴趣。他思考过社会规范是如何改变人们聚在一起的方式的，他研究过
how romantic preferences have changed over time, and he's examined how online dating is linked to the psychological phenomenon known as the paradox of choice. Like there's too much goddamn jam out there, like there's iPhone apps that literally tell paradox of choice. A Zezus core it in a book with the sociologist Eric Kleinenberg, it's called Modern Romance. We taped a live conversation at George Washington University's List Narodatorium and we played an excerpt for you in the fall. We are working on new podcasts this week and we played an excerpt for you in the fall. We are working on new podcasts this week and we thought you might enjoy this encore presentation.
浪漫偏好是如何随时间变化的，他还研究了网络交友如何与被称为“选择悖论”的心理学现象联系在一起。就像外面有太多该死的果酱，就像有些iPhone应用字面意思上就在讲述选择悖论。阿齐兹与社会学家埃里克·克莱嫩伯格合著了一本书，名叫《现代情爱》。我们在乔治华盛顿大学的里斯纳罗多礼堂录制了一场现场对话，并在秋季为您播放了其中的一个片段。本周我们正在制作新的播客，秋季时我们为您播放过其中的一个片段。本周我们正在制作新的播客，我们觉得您可能会喜欢这次返场节目。
If you know anything about a Z's, we don't need to tell you, this episode is going to be a little racy. If you're on the car with kids, you might want to save it for later. I want to jump to one particular section that you start right at the top of the book, looking at ways in which people text one another. And the fact that people turn out to be surprisingly bad at texting. Actually, I should correct that. What you're saying is that men turn out to be surprisingly bad at texting women.
如果你对阿齐兹有所了解，我们就不用多说了，这一期节目会有点少儿不宜。如果你正带着孩子开车，你可能想留到以后再听。我想聊聊书中最开头的一个特定部分，即人们发短信的方式。事实上，人们发短信的水平出奇地差。其实，我应该纠正一下。我的意思是，男人们发短信给女性的水平出奇地差。
Yeah. Well, I will say this, OK? When we ask women, like, well, what are the things you'd like when guys text, like, what are the factors that make a text that you like? And kind of the consensus we got was asking them to do a specific thing at a specific time, saying something that maybe recalled an interaction some asking them to do a specific thing at a specific time,
是的。嗯，我会这么说，好吗？当我们问女性，比如，当男人发短信时，你们喜欢什么，比如，什么样的因素能构成一条你喜欢的短信？我们得到的共识基本上是，要求她们在特定时间做特定事情，说一些可能让人回忆起某种互动的话，要求她们在特定时间做特定事情，
saying something that maybe recalled an interaction that they had in the past to just show that you were engaged and this was something that you were into. And the last thing was just some sort of humor is also helpful. And when the book we talk about this stuff, and it's not from the perspective of this
说一些可能让人回忆起你们过去有过互动的话，以此来表明你的投入，并且这也是你感兴趣的事。最后一点是，带点幽默感也会有所帮助。在书中我们谈到了这些内容，它不是从“这就是你应该做的”这种角度出发的，更像是人们怎么会不知道只需做到这些。就像，门槛低得惊人。就像，门槛低到这种程度实在是很吓人。我想知道能否请你朗读书中关于男人们在这方面表现得多么糟糕的一小段。这里正好有一段关于一个试图给女人发短信的男人的摘录。如果你想找的话，它在第42页。好的。好吧。有些人说你给别人发短信内容并不重要，他们喜欢你就是喜欢你。在采访了数百名单身人士后，
is what you should do, more like how the people people not know like this is all you have to do. Like, the bar is startlingly low. Like it's this really like very scary how low the bar is. I'm wondering whether we can have you just read a short excerpt from the book that talks about how badly men are doing this. And you have a little excerpt here with a guy who tries to text a woman. It's on page 42 for anyone if you want to be a girl. Okay. Okay. Some people say it doesn't matter what you text someone. They like you, they like you. After interviewing hundreds of singles,
我可以从科学的角度证实，这完全是胡扯。对于那些怀疑我的人，这里有一个例子，来自我在2014年春天在芝加哥剧院的一场演出。在那次巡演中，在讲完关于发短信的素材后，我会问观众中是否有人最近遇到了某人并一直在互发短信。如果有，他们就会上台，我会挑选几个人，朗读、分析并询问他们信息中发生了什么。在当场演出中，我和雷切尔进行了交谈，她在一位好朋友的婚礼上认识了一个男人。碰巧的是，这个男人也是她姐姐的朋友，所以她和对方有很大的机会约会。她是单身的，她也有兴趣，他所需要做的就是发一条简单的短信，做个自我介绍，
I can scientifically confirm that this is total bullsh**. For those who doubt me, here's an example from a show I did at the Chicago Theater in the spring of 2014. During that tour after material about texting, I would ask if any one of the audience had recently met someone and had been texting back and forth. They had, they would come into the stage and I would pick a few people and read, analyze and ask them about what was happening in their messages. At this particular show, I was speaking with Rachel, who had met a guy at a good friend's wedding. As it happened, the guy was also a friend of her sisters, so we had a pretty good shot at a first date with her. She was single, she was interested, all he had to do was send her a simple message, introducing
并邀请她做点什么。以下是发生的事情。他发出了第一条信息。嗨，雷切尔！既然我在玛丽莎和克里斯的婚礼上一直没机会邀请你跳舞，我是克里斯在普渡大学的老室友。他和你的姐姐给了我你的电话号码。我想打个招呼，算是以发短信的方式做个自我介绍。
himself, and asking her to do something. Here's what happened. He sends his first message. Hi, Rachel! Since I never got a chance to ask you to dance at Marissa and Chris's wedding, I'm Chris's old roommate from Purdue. He and your sister gave you your number. I wanted to say hi and sort of texty introduce myself.
希望你周末过得愉快。点点点。希望能早日和你聊天。雷切尔在10分钟后回复了。嘿，很高兴认识你。目前正在享受我的生日周末，有超多好吃的墨西哥菜。生日赶上五月五日节就会这样。
I hope you had a great weekend. Dot dot dot. Hope to chat with you soon. Rachel wrote back 10 minutes later. Hey, great to meet you. Currently enjoying my birthday weekend with lots of good Mexican food. It happens when your birthday is in Cinco de Mayo.
也希望你周末过快。你不久后回复了。我读了上一条信息才完全意识到，我没有写上我的名字。哈哈哈哈。我是威尔，笑脸。我读了上一条信息才完全意识到，我没有写上我的名字。哈哈。我是威尔，笑脸。祝你生日快乐。而且非常喜欢五月五日节。
Hope you had a great weekend too. You wrote back shortly. I totally realize upon reading my last message, I didn't include my name. Ha, ha, ha. I'm Will, smiley face. I totally realize upon reading my last message I didn't include my name. Haha. I'm Will, smiley face. Feliz cumpleaños as well. And totally digging on the synchote of myothene.
雷切尔再也没有回过威尔。在收到几条这种性质的信息后，雷切尔停止了回复。我们谁也不认识威尔。你可能是一个心地善良、英俊潇洒的男士。但我们能了解到的只有这些信息。而这些信息在我们的脑海中塑造了一个非常书呆子气、令人毛骨悚然的白人怪胎。最后是白人怪胎。因此，你在书中指出的一点是，当有人给你发短信时，在回复时间上存在一场军备竞赛。如果你立刻回复短信，你就会瞬间失去所有筹码，因为你表现出了兴趣，表现出了绝望。
Rachel never met Will. After a few messages of this nature, Rachel stopped responding. None of us know Will. You may be a kind, handsome man with a heart of gold. But all we have to go on is those messages. And those messages have shaped in our minds a very dorky, terrifyingly Caucasian weirdo. Finally Caucasian, weirdo. So one of the things that you point out in the book is that there's this arms race in waiting when someone texts you. That if you respond to a text right away, you instantly lose all leverage because you indicate interest, you indicate desperation.
所以当别人发短信给你时，你会等待。现在那个人也在跟你玩同样的游戏，所以他们也会等上一会儿才回复你短信，于是你们就进行了一场漫长的等待游戏。这太诡异了，而且诡异在于每个人都知道别人在搞什么鬼，但他们还是这么做。比如，“哦，你要等20分钟。哦，你开会去了吗？不，你根本没开会，你是故意在等的。好吧，你猜怎么着？我要等40分钟。你开会去了吗？不，你他妈的根本没开会。你是故意在等的。好吧，你猜怎么着？我要等40分钟。我要把时间翻倍，因为我也有事要忙。”
So you wait when someone texts you. And now that person is playing the same game with you So they wait and respond to texting you and now you have this extended waiting game It's so weird and it's weird because everyone knows what people are doing and they still can do it Like oh, you're gonna wait 20 minutes. Oh did you have a meeting? No, you didn't you were waiting on purpose Well, guess what I'm gonna wait 40 minutes Did you have a meeting? No, you fucking didn't. You were waiting on purpose. Well, guess what? I'm gonna wait 40 minutes. I'm gonna double that shit because I have shit going on too.
其实并没有，但我得假装我有。这太诡异了。你知道，那是让我觉得很有趣的事。比如，我曾纳闷，为什么当我单身且不得不面对这一切时，那种等待会让我发疯？我会抓狂，而且你知道，在书中我们查阅了大量研究，我们跟许多非常聪明的人聊过，他们向我解释了原因，这确实说得通。基本上，这个想法是，比方说，
Not really, but I'm gonna pretend like I do. It's so weird. You know, that was the thing that was interesting to me. Like, I wondered like, why did that waiting drive me crazy when I was single and like had to deal with that? Like, I would go crazy and and you know in the book we looked at a lot of studies we talked to a lot of very smart people and they explained it to me and it made sense like basically the idea is like let's say
你是个男人，你遇到了三个女性，你给她们三个都发了短信，其中两个给你回了信息，回信的那两个总算让你安心了，对吧？但第三个没有给你回信。所以她们没有让你安心，反而制造了不确定性。不确定性是非常强大的，它会一直留在你的脑海里，让你觉得，“怎么回事？我做了什么？我对这个人做了什么不好的事吗？我喜欢我吗？发生什么了？发生什么了？”因此，那个人在你的脑海中占据了更多的存在感。而仅仅是这种存在感，有时就能发展成吸引力。所以当她们最终让你安心时，对你来说意义就更重大了。
you're you're a guy you meet three women and you text all three of them and two of them write you back the two that write you back they kind of put your mind at ease, right? But the third one has not written you back. So they're not putting your mind at ease and they've created uncertainty. And uncertainty is very powerful and it sticks to your mind and you're like, what's going on? What did I do? Did I do something wrong to this person? I like me. What's happening? What's happening? And so that person has more presence of your mind. And just that presence on your mind can sometimes develop into attraction. So when they finally do put your mind at ease, it's more meaningful to you.
但另一方面，在某个特定时刻，如果你等得太久，对方就会想，“去他妈的这个人，他们等太久了，去他们的，我要跟那些很快回我信息的其他人之一出去玩了，或者诸如此类。”所以这从来都不是一个精确的事情。没有什么话是你说了之后，
But there's also kind of like, at a certain point, if you wait too long, then the person's like, well, screw this person, like they wait too long, like screw them, I'm gonna hang out with these, one of these other people that wrote me back quickly or whatever. So it's never quite a precise thing. There's not like something you can say where
就好像，“好吧，如果你等这么几分钟，效果就会完美。”所有这些情况因人而异。这里面有很多因素。但我们了解到的一点是，随着年龄越来越小，这个等待的时间量会减少。比如，如果你告诉——我32岁，如果你跟某个——我的眼睛是，哦，如果对方等了，你知道的，一天或者六个小时，会有点让人心神不宁。如果你和某个上大学的人交谈，他们会说：“我五分钟没收到消息了。发生什么事了？”这个窗口正变得越来越小。
it's like, okay, if you wait like this amount of minutes, you're going to be perfect. Like all those things vary from person to person. There's a lot of factors. But the thing we learned is like that, that amount of time decreases as you get to younger people. Like if you tell I'm 32, if you talk to someone, my eyes are like, oh, if they wait like, you know, a day or like six hours, it's a little unnerving. If you talk to someone who's like, in college, they're like, I haven't heard anything in five minutes. What's happened? That window is getting smaller and smaller.
节目稍事休息后，我们将探讨不断扩大的约会选择池如何既是福也是祸。这与心理学中一个被称为“选择悖论”的概念有关。当你约会时，或者当你买果酱时，拥有太多选择可能会让人头疼。你知道，你去约会，然后你去上厕所，像几块果酱发信息给你，你会想：这他妈到底是什么？请继续收听。欢迎回到《隐藏的大脑》。
When we come back, we'll talk about how the ever-growing pool of dating options can be both a blessing and a curse. This is related to an idea and psychology known as the paradox of choice. Having too many choices can be tough when you're dating, or when you're buying jam. You know, you go on a date and you go to the bathroom like a few pieces of jam, of text to you, you're like, what the f*** is this? Stay with us. Welcome back to Hidden Brain.
阿齐兹·安萨里在他的书中谈到了如今人们拥有的海量约会选择。这引出了社会科学中一直在探讨的一个概念，即所谓的选择悖论。对于现在约会的人来说，最大的改变之一就是，你们拥有的选择比以往任何一代人都多。你知道，当我们和住在退休之家的老人们交谈时，你们拥有的选择比以往任何一代人都多。当我们和住在退休之家的老人们交谈时，这真的很有趣。
Aziz and Sarri talk in his book about the vast number of dating choices people have today. This led to an idea that's been explored in the social sciences, it's known as the paradox of choice. One of the big changes for people that are like dating now is you have more options than any generation of people ever. You know, when we talk to people that were living in retirement homes and stuff, it was you have more options than any generation of people ever. When we talked to people that were living in retirement homes and stuff, it was really interesting.
他们谈到了——特别是女性——这真的很有趣。她们说，好吧，你知道，20岁的时候，我和父母住在一起。我没有机会去追求教育或我自己的事业。直到我结婚，我才真正成为了成年人。附近有个小伙子，人挺不错的。我想离开家，当时我就想，好吧，我结婚算了，你知道的。她们真的是这么说的，我就觉得，听起来确实如此，因为她们就像有些女性，
They talked about how, especially the women, it was really interesting. They were saying, well, you know, it's 20 years old. I was living with my parents. I didn't have the opportunity to pursue education or my own career. I didn't really get to become an adult until I got married. There was some guy with neighborhood. He was pretty nice. I wanted to get out of the house and I was like all right I'll get married, you know And they really said that I was like it sounds like it because they're like some of the women
她们真的很开心，觉得“哦，我们培养出了这种羁绊”，但其他女性则认为“并没有那么深厚的羁绊”。对那些世代的人来说，结婚可以说是成年第一步。但对我们而言，这个，你知道，现在的人们，结婚往往不是第一步。你知道，你上大学，追求事业，在许多不同的地方生活，并在你人生的各个不同阶段结识形形色色的人。你拥有了整整一个被称为“新兴成年期”的人生阶段，是的，你通过这种方式结识了很多人，再加上网络交友的因素，你的选择比养老院那些世代的人们所能想象的还要多。
They're really happy and they're like oh we grew to have this debon but other women are like no not as much of a bond and And getting married was kind of the first step in adulthood For those generations. But for us, this, you know, people now, marriages is always the first step. You know, you go to college, you pursue a career, you live in a bunch of different places, and you meet so many people throughout all these different stages of your life. You have this whole stage of life that is referred to as emerging adulthood and yeah you meet so many people that way and then you add in the online dating aspect of things and you have more options
所以我的意思是，我能理解为什么只有三个人的约会池太小，以至于无法真正找到你的终身伴侣，但拥有3万或30万人的约会池却让人难以应付，因为所发生的情况是，每当你遇到一个潜在有趣的人时，你脑海深处的微小声音就会说：“如果你再等两天，你就能找到比这个人更好的人。”嗯，对，好吧，问题在于，我们所指的——这位我们在书中采访过的绅士巴里·施瓦茨，他对选择做了大量研究，并写了一本名叫
than anyone could have possibly imagined in those generations of retirement homes. So I mean I can see why a dating pool of three people is too small to actually find your life partner but a dating pool of 30,000 or 300,000 is just unmanageable because what happens is every time you meet someone who's potentially interesting, a little voice in the back of your head says, if you wait for another two days, you could find someone better than this. Well, yeah, well, the problem is, what we refer to, what this gentleman, Barry Schwartz, that we interviewed in the book, he does a lot of research on choice and he wrote this book
《选择悖论》的书，该书的核心论点之一就是，你知道的，当你拥有更多选择时，你的直觉是：“哦，那太好了，我有更多的选择，有更多东西可挑，我会更快乐。”但实际上，当他们进行了一项又一项研究后发现，选择越多，你就越难做出决定；而当你真正做出决定时，你的满意度反而会降低，因为你会一直在想自己是不是做错了决定，或者其他选项中是否有一个会更适合你。
called The Paradox of Choice and kind of the kind of main thesis of that book is the idea that like you know when you have more options your instinct is oh well that's better I have more off than more things to choose from I'll be happier. But in reality when they do study after study they find the more options you have the harder it is to make a decision and when you do make a decision, you end up being less satisfied because you're thinking about whether you made the wrong decision or whether one of these other things would have been a better match for you.
然后，那个非常著名的研究是他们在一家杂货店里做的研究，他们摆出了两个不同的果酱陈列台。一个陈列台大约有5种果酱，另一个陈列台大约有——你知道的，5种果酱，而另一个陈列台有大约36种果酱。每当是5种果酱时，人们更有可能购买果酱；而当有36种果酱时，他们简直不知所措，不知道该怎么办，最后有时甚至不买果酱了。所以，他们还说了这样一句话，真的很有趣，他们说，哦，从那36种果酱——更大的那个陈列台买果酱的人，无论如何，如果我的数字记错了，
And then the really famous study is this study they did in a grocery store where they had two different displays with jams. And one display had like five jams and one display had like you know five jams and the other display had like 36 jams and whenever it was the five jams people were way more likely to buy the jams and when they had the 36 jams they were just overwhelmed and they didn't know what to do and they ended up not buying jams sometimes. So and they also said this which is really interesting they said like oh people that bought the jam from the 36, like the bigger display, whatever, if I'm getting these numbers wrong,
我是在用自己的话复述，但核心意思是准确的。当他们从选项更多的大陈列台购买时，人们报告说对果酱的满意度较低，我觉得这真的太滑稽了。有人吃了果酱后竟然觉得“这果酱不让人满意，这果酱有什么毛病，上面写着它是草莓味的”。但我们在书中提到的是，在我看来，这完全适用于现代浪漫关系，因为我的意思是，外面有太多该死的果酱了。就像，你知道，你去约会，你去上厕所，
I'm paraphrasing, but the core of the thing is right. The, when they bought from the one with the bigger display with more options, the people reported being less satisfied with the jam, which I found really hilarious. The idea that someone ate jam and like, this jam's not satisfying. It's wrong with this jam. It says it tastes like strawberries. But the thing we say in the book is like, to me, like that totally applies to modern romance, because I mean, like, there's just too much goddamn jam out there. Like, you know, you go on a date and you go to the bathroom
就像几块果酱发信息给你，你会想：这他妈到底是什么？你上网一看，外面有那么多的果酱。有些iPhone应用字面意思上会告诉你，附近有没有哪个果酱此时此刻就想被吃掉。我的意思是，你能怎么办？你知道，你在书中谈到了你采访过的那个家伙，我想他是在match.com上。
like a few pieces of jam of text to you. You're like, what the fuck is this? You go online, there's so much jam out there. There's iPhone apps that literally tell you if there's jam nearby that wants to get eaten at that very moment. I mean, what can you do? You know, you're talking the book about this guy you interviewed who I think was on match.com
而且你实际上有机会观察他做出选择，他当时在浏览女性的照片，然后决定自己是否喜欢她们。我不知道你是否还记得这个特定的轶事，但我想知道你能否给我们讲讲。好的，我记得这家伙。所以他，他看起来不像一个——他不是那种肌肉男或什么的，他不是个帅哥，他只是那种——这么说可能有点刻薄，但他只是那种平庸的白男。然后他登录了自己的账号，上面显示——哦，在这个案例中他用的是match.com账号。他看着屏幕，然后就像是，而且上面显示——哦，在这个案例中他用的是match.com账号。他看着屏幕，然后就像是，上面显示“你有这么多匹配对象”。我看着那张照片，
And you actually got to observe him making choices where he was sort of reviewing pictures of women And then deciding whether he liked them or not I don't know if you remember the specific anecdote, but I'm wondering if you can just tell us about it Yeah, I remember this guy. So he just, he didn't seem like a, like he wasn't like a hunk or anything like, he wasn't a stud, he was just kind of like, and this is mean, but he was just kind of like a mediocre white guy. And he, uh, he logged on to his account and, and it said like, oh, he was a match.com account in this case. And he looks on it and he was just like, uh, and, and said like oh you he was a match.com account in this case And he looks on it and he was just like and it said like you have these many matches and I looked at the photo
心想：哇，那个女人非常有吸引力。然后他看了看她的个人资料，琢磨着要不要给她发个消息。他说：“算了。”然后我就问：“什么？你为什么不给她发消息？”他说：“嗯，她喜欢红袜队。”然后我说：“什么？”接着我看到他去看另一个女人并忽略了她。然后他又忽略了另一个女人。然后他给这个女人发了一条简短的信息。这让我大开眼界。
I was like wow that woman is very attractive and then he he looked at her profile and He was like debating whether he's gonna send her a message. He's like nah, and I was like what? Why why are you not sending her message? And he is like, mm, she likes the red socks. And I was like, what? And then I saw him go to another woman and ignore her. And then he ignored one other woman. And then he sent this other woman like a quick message. And it blew my mind.
因为如果那三个被他打叉的女人中的任何一个，在20岁的时候在酒吧里看到他并对他笑一下，他都会——他都会疯掉的。他会疯掉的。那些都是漂亮的女性。她们非常有趣，而且——仅凭我在个人资料中看到的微薄信息——看起来是聪明、有思想的人，你知道的，她们看起来是有趣的人，对这家伙来说绝对算得上是个好姻缘。但现在他却觉得：“天哪，随便吧。外面有这么多人，
Because if any of those other three women that he put an ax on, if they'd seen him in a bar, like 20 years ago and like smiled at him, he would have, he would have went crazy. He would have crazy. There's beautiful women. They were very interesting and and and seem like intelligent thoughtful people just, you know, based on what little ice off in the profile, but they seem like interesting people where he would be a catch for this guy. But now he was just like, man, whatever. Like there's so many
谁在乎呢。”所以，但我觉得你所描述的这件事真的很悲哀，那就是人们在看着这些照片，并根据非常非常少的信息对另一个人做出判断，而且往往是根据他们自己认为对自己很重要的标准。
people out here who cares. So, but here's was just like, man, whatever, like there's so many people out here, who cares? So, but here's the thing that I find really sad about what you're describing, which is that people are looking at these pictures, and they're making judgements about this other person based on this very, very small amount of information, and often based on things that they think are important criteria to them.
所以如果你问人们，他们会告诉你，我想要个这么高或那么矮的人，或者这种发色，或者这种身材的人，诸如此类。但如果你实际去看看人们最终和谁在一起的数据，人们往往并没有和他们嘴上说自己正在寻找的人在一起。因此，如果他们根据自己以为拥有的标准去淘汰人，他们可能正在淘汰自己的灵魂伴侣。
So if you ask people, they will tell you, I want someone who's this tall or this short, or this color hair, or this body profile, and so on. But if you actually look at the data of who people end up with, people often don't end up with the people that they say they're actually looking for. So if they eliminate people based on the criteria they think they have, they might be eliminating their soulmates.
完全正确。是的。我的意思是，有大量研究表明，我们对于自己真正喜欢什么一无所知，你知道的。每当他们查看这些在线网站并观察人们嘴上说自己偏爱什么以及他们实际追求什么时，总是存在巨大的反差，就好像你嘴上说你不喜欢这个，但那实际上正是你感兴趣的。我认为这可以追溯到这种想法，你知道的，所有这些在线约会网站，你拥有所有的过滤器和所有这些东西，但其实这些都不重要。这真的只是
Exactly. Yeah. I mean, there's a plenty of studies that show that we're horrible at knowing what we really like, you know. Whenever they look at these online sites and they see what people say they prefer and what they actually go after, it's always there's always a big contrast of like what you said you didn't like this, but that's actually what you're interested in. I think that goes back to this idea of like, you know, all these online dating sites, you have all these filters and all this stuff, but not of it really matters. Like, it's really just
关于你和某人面对面的这种化学反应，看看是否有某种火花或连接，当你在现实生活中与某人有这种连接时，你不会停下来然后说：“等等，等等，等一下。但你最喜欢的电影是什么？”你会觉得，你根本不在乎，你与这个人在一起互动得很开心，而且很有趣。而且我认为有时在这些在线网站上，那些似乎有点沮丧的人是那些试图找到完美伴侣、花大量时间来回发信息并试图找到这种难以捉摸的默契的人。而实际上，你只有在现实中才能找到这种默契。我认为网络交友带来的一个重大启示正如海伦·费舍尔这位女性告诉我们的那样，她是一位极其聪明的社会
about like this connection that you have with someone in person and seeing if there's some sort of spark or connection, like, when you have this connection with someone in real life, you don't stop and go, wait, wait, wait, hold on. But what are your favorite movies? Like, you're just, you don't give a s***, you're engaged with the person and you like it and it's fun. And I think sometimes with these online sites, the people that seemed to be a little frustrated were people that were trying to find this perfect person and spending this extended period of time like messaging back and forth and trying to find this elusive rapport. And really, you just find that in person. And I think one of the kind of big takeaway from online dating was what this woman Helen Fisher told us is and she's like this amazingly smart social
学家。她还与match.com合作过，她说：“你知道，这些网站不应该被称为在线交友网站，而应该被称为在线介绍服务，因为你想要在现实中与这个人见面。”当我意识到这一点时，就好像，你知道的，你不会在网上遇到完美的人，你在网上遇到的是一个人，但要发现他们是否完美，你必须看你们在现实中相处得怎么样。换句话说，你真的必须要经历大约第三次约会，
eyes. She's also works with match.com and she's like, you know, these sides shouldn't be called online dating science as you're called online introduction services because you want to meet this person in person. And when I realize it's like, you know, you don't meet the perfect person online, you meet a person online, but to find out they're perfect, you have to see how you are in person. So in other words, you really have to get to sort of date three
才能真正弄清楚这个人是否适合你。但如果你一直处于向右滑、向左滑的模式，你是不会走到那一步的。甚至比向右滑、向左滑模式更糟糕的是这种模式：“哦，让我继续发信息，看看这到底是不是我梦寐以求的人。”你知道，Tinder其实认为，那些类似左滑右滑的应用，
before you actually figure out whether this person is for you or not. But if you're in constantly swipe right, swipe left mode, you're not going to get to that point. Or even worse than the swipe right swipe left mode is this mode of like, oh, let me just keep sending messages and see if this is my dream person. You know, Tinder actually think, and those kind of swipe apps,
我完全能理解它们是怎么出现的。有些人会说：“哦，那看起来太肤浅了。这就是一张照片，然后只需滑动来决定你是否要跟某人见面。”但我的意思是，当你走进一家酒吧或派对时，你在看着人们，然后心里想着：不，不，对，你就是在做这种事。
I totally see why those came about. Like, there's some people that would say, oh, that seems really shallow. This is the picture and just like swipe in the side if you're gonna meet someone. But I mean, when you go into a bar or a party, you're looking at people and going, no, no, yes, you're doing that.
所以我正试图内化你的教训，那就是：结识新的人没那么重要，花时间与你遇到的人相处以弄清楚他们是否真的合适才更重要。所以我们在书中提到的一点是我们所谓的“通过重复获得喜爱度的弗洛·里达理论”，其基本含义是——基本上是在说，是的，确实有这样的人，当然有。
So I'm trying to internalize your lesson, which is that it's less important to meet new people and more important to spend time with the people you meet to figure out if they're actually right-footed. So the thing we mentioned in the book is what we call the flow riota theory of acquired likability through repetition, which basically was basically saying like, yes, there are people, yes, of course.
但我愿意相信外面有很多优秀的人，也有许多我们很快就否定的人。如果你应用这个理论，这个理论基本上就像我们都是弗洛·里达的歌，你知道吗？你第一次听到时会想：好吧，弗洛·里达。我以前听过这首，拿开，离我远点！然后你一直听到它，它就盘旋在你的脑海里，你会想：弗洛·里达，你又来了，我们跳舞吧！今天下午我正在读这本书的一个章节，它勾起了一些几年前的回忆，涉及纽约的一位特定国会议员。以及他和一位来自拉斯维加斯的名叫莉萨的女性在Facebook上交流过的信息。
But I'd like to think there's a lot of great people out there and a lot of people that were quick to dismiss If you apply this theory, the theory is basically like we're all like a flow writer song, you know? The first time you hear us you're like all right flow writer. I've heard this before Get it out of here, leave me alone And then you keep hearing it and it gets stuck in your head and you're like, flow right at you, you've done it again, let's dance! I was reading a section of the book this afternoon that brought back some memories from some years ago, involving a certain congressman from New York. And some Facebook messages he had exchanged with a woman named Lisa from Las Vegas.
我想知道你是否能为我们朗读这段交流。当然。我想问你是否认为这些在线网站和这项技术增加了轻率行为和不忠的风险。当然。好的。我记得读过安东尼·韦纳的Facebook信息。不忠和不忠的风险。当然。好的。我记得读过安东尼·韦纳的Facebook信息。
I'm wondering if you might be able to read this exchange for us. Sure. And I want to ask you whether you think these online sites and this technology has increased the risk of indiscretions and infidelity. Sure. All right. I remember reading the Anthony Weiner Facebook messages. of indiscretions and infidelity. Sure. All right. I remember reading the Anthony Weiner Facebook messages.
看到他只是给全国各地的随机女性发信息，看着这些对话从无害迅速升级为非常色情的内容，简直令人难以置信。这是他和其中一位女性——一个名叫莉萨的来自拉斯维加斯的女士——的聊天记录。韦纳和莉萨，抱歉又把这个拿出来说，伙计们，但它实在太迷人了。
Seeing the way he was just messaging random women all over the country and watching the messages, quickly escalate from innocuous to very sexual with unbelievable. This is a transcript of a chat session he had with one of these women, a lady named Lisa from Las Vegas. Weiner and Lisa, sorry to bring this back guys, but it is fascinating.
莉萨：我正试图找到那个我爱上的、了不起的安东尼·韦纳，因为你前几天冲那些该死的共和党人吼叫，而且你在每日秀上搞笑得要死。你的好友请求满了。你必须加我为好友。你太棒了。安东尼：谢谢你，莉萨。很高兴你支持我。你的好友请求满了。你必须加我为好友。你太棒了。安东尼：谢谢你，莉萨。很高兴你支持我。你一直在关注那个怪咖在分享我们的角逐角度吗？莉萨：她有多疯狂？谁需要社会保障、医疗保险或教育？如果这个怪胎赢了我的州，我发誓我不得不搬家了。她可能比佩林还要蠢，而这很难超越。
Lisa, I'm trying to find the wonderful Anthony Weiner who I fell in love with for yelling at those damn Republicans the other day, and you were as funny as hell on the daily show. Your friend requests are full. You must friend me. You were awesome. Anthony, thank you Lisa. Glad you had my back. Your friend requests are full. You must friend me. You are awesome. Anthony, thank you Lisa. Glad you had my back. You keeping an eye on that. Wackadoodle sharing an angle for us. Lisa, how insane is she? Who needs Social Security, Medicare or education? If this Wacko wins my state, I swear I'll have to move. She may be dumber than plain and that is tough to burn.
我发誓我不得不搬家了。她可能比佩林还要蠢，而这很难找到。就像这张你可爱的新照片，当你来拉斯维加斯帮我痛击右翼疯子时。安东尼：这是我的泳池照片。很高兴你喜欢。我准备好去一趟拉斯维加斯了。白天讲真话，晚上有什么计划吗？问号。莉萨：这是一个非常带有暗示性的问题。我为我们准备了各种晚间计划。你什么时候来？安东尼：不知道，开个我无法拒绝的条件吧。莉萨：为了让我们进入状态，首先我们要连续观看《每日秀》和《扣扣报告》的节目。然后，为了真正增添情趣，我们去面对面看我所有邻居分享的年度院子标志。然后，当我们真的很火热时，我们去书店，把所有乏味的平装书都换成《无畏的希望》的副本！我大概一周做一次这个，你可以看出我是个非常令人兴奋的女孩。
I swear I'll have to move. She may be dumber than plain and that is tough to find. Like this cute new pick of you, when you come into Vegas to help me beat up the right wing crazies. Anthony, this is my pool my finger shot. Glad you like. I'm ready for a Vegas trip. Truth telling during the day, got a nine plan for us? Question mark. Lisa, that was a very loaded question. I've got all kinds of night plans for us. When are you coming? Anthony, don't know, make me an offer. I can't refuse. Lisa, to get us in the mood, first we watch back-to-back episodes of the Daily Show and Colbert Report. Then, to really spice things up, we go to face all of my neighbors sharing annual yard signs. Then, when we are really hot, we go to the bookstore and cover all of the bland back books with copies of the audacity of hope! I do this about once a week, you can tell I'm a very exciting girl.
或者如果这不是你的菜，我们也可以喝醉然后疯狂做爱。对我来说，最冒犯的部分是他使用了“怪咖”（whackadoodle）这个词。最冒犯的部分是他使用了“怪咖”这个词。还有，你抓住了那个滑动的、几乎是潜意识的一眨眼就会错过的对性爱的不经意暗示吗？就是当她说他们可以疯狂做爱的时候。那么，你对这些怎么看？这些网络技术是否让我们更容易做出轻率和不忠的行为？还是这只是我们一贯本性的一种表现？我绝对认为，这绝对是，
Or if this is not your thing, we can just get drunk and have mad passionate sex. For me, the most offensive part was that he used the word whackadoodle. the most offensive part was that he used the word whackadoodle. Also, did you catch that slide, almost subliminal blink and you might miss it allusion to sex? It was when she said they could have mad passionate sex. So, what do you think of these? Have these online technologies made us more prone to indiscretion and infidelity? Or is this just a manifestation of how we've always been? I think it definitely, there's definitely,
如果你想涉足轻率行为，如果你有这些网络工具，如果你有手机，如果你有手机，你就会拥有一个非常私密的世界，你可以在其中进行各种无人知晓的狗屁倒灶的事。就像我们在书中讲述的那个人，他说他们有个同事，彼此很友好。她结婚了，她发了一条短信
if you're trying to get involved in indiscretions, you, if you have these online things and you have your phone, if you have your phone, you have this very private world where you can conduct all sorts of s**t that no one knows about. It's just where we tell in the book of this person who says they were, they had like a work colleague and they were friendly with each other. She was married and she sent like a text message
关于某种工作相关的事，然后他回复了，后来他看到了某个挺有趣、能让他想起她的东西，于是他发了一条信息，然后他们开始你来我往地开玩笑，这种默契开始建立起来，最终他们在电话里进行了一种非常亲密的交流，他们通了很长时间的电话，这变成了一种非常亲密的事情，最终导致了一些不忠行为。有趣的是，那个家伙说：“你知道的，如果我没有手机短信，我就不会发那第一条开始通往这种默契的信息，
about something once and it was like a work related and he wrote back and then later he saw something that was kind of funny that reminded him of her and he sent a message and they started joking back and forth and this rapport started developing and they eventually had this like very like intimate thing going on the phone where they were like having a long conversations and it became this very intimate thing going on the phone where they were like having a long conversations and it became It's very intimate thing and it eventually led to some some infidelity and It was interesting because the guy was like, you know if if I didn't have text message I wouldn't have sent that first message that started leading to that rapport You know, I would never have called her at her home
我绝不会给她家里打电话说：‘嘿，你看到那个东西了吗，你知道的。’但有了手机，你就可以建立起这种迅速升级的关系，你知道的，我绝不会给她家里打电话说：‘嘿，你看到那个东西了吗，你知道的。’但有了手机，你就可以建立起这种迅速升级的关系，它真的会迅速升级。呃……而且我也觉得，你知道的，在韦纳的事件中，就像他能够通过那次会面稍微试探一下底线，比如他可以说：‘不知道，也许开个我无法拒绝的条件吧，你可以去奇利餐厅’，然后她会说：‘哦，听起来一点意思都没有’，
I'd be like, hey, did you see that thing like, you know But with your phone you you can kind of build these kind of things that really escalate very quickly you know i would never have called her at her home and like hey did you see that thing like you know but with your phone you you you can kind of build these kind of things that really escalate very quickly uh... and also i think like you know in the in the in the and the winter thing is like all he's able to test the waters with that meeting a little bit where he's like don't know maybe enough for a rickian refuse you can be like oh well we'll go to chiles and you'll be like all that doesn't sound fun
但她立刻就领会了并开始谈论色情内容，于是他知道：‘好吧，这是一件关于性的事，她愿意。’然后在我读的那条信息之后，就像闸门打开了，接着就是所有的照片和所有那些东西。我认为你不能准确地说这是否导致了不忠行为数量的增加。我确实认为它某些方面的特质确实让它更容易促成这种行为。你在书中谈论的一点是，网络交友如何迅速成为许多人相识的方式，但你也发现这对于同性恋伴侣来说尤其如此。对于同性恋伴侣而言，网络交友真的已经成为人们相识的主导方式。你认为这是为什么？你认为这说明了什么？
but she she immediately like got it and started getting sexual and he knew, okay, this is a sexual thing, she's down and then after that message that I read, like the floodgates opened and then there was all the photos and all that stuff. I don't think you can kind of accurately say whether it's led to an increase on the amount of infidelity
嗯，这与一种被称为“稀薄市场”的现象有关，你知道，我曾和这样一位女性交谈过，她在晚年的时候——她曾和一个男人结过婚，后来离婚了，然后基本上决定：“你知道吗，我是个同性恋，我一辈子都是个同性恋。”
that's going on. I do think there's certain aspects of it that make it a little more lend itself to it. One of the things you talk about in the book is about how online dating is rapidly becoming the way many people meet, but you also find that this is especially true for same-sex couples. That same-sex couples online dating is really become the dominant way people meet one another. Why do you think that's going on? What do you think that's going on what
她住在德克萨斯州的一个小镇上，然后她开始网上交友并去约会之类的。我当时想了想，心想：哇。如果那是23年前的她，情况就会大不相同了。你知道的，身处德克萨斯州这样一个
do you think it means well that is about something a phenomenon uh... related to what what referred to a thin markets you know i i spoke with this woman who who like late in her life like she was married to a guy and then she got divorced and this kind of decided like you know what i'm a lesbian like i've been a lesbian my whole life
小镇，人们可能对那种事情没那么开放，情况会艰难得多，而现在她可以上网并结识其他人，这确实是一个巨大的因素。所以这在某种程度上可以说是技术积极的一面，不是吗？因为它让那些拥有少数群体兴趣（如果你愿意这么说）或某种特殊兴趣的人不会永远孤独，而是能够真正找到与他们的兴趣和需求相匹配的人，
and she lives in this small town in Texas and she started online dating and going on on dates and stuff like that. And I thought about that. I was like, wow. Like if that was her 23 years ago, that would have been a much different thing. You know, being in a place like Texas
这就是技术所实现的功能。它确实在那些细分市场或诸如此类的领域发挥了巨大帮助，我认为这是一个很好的观点：对于所有这些事情，我觉得这本书提出的重大问题之一是，所有这些东西到底是好还是坏？我认为对于每件事都没有单一答案，两者兼有，这真的取决于你如何使用这些工具。像网上交友，有一种观念是：“哦，每个人都在手机上，每个人都认为外面有更好的东西，
in a small town where maybe people aren't as open to that kind of stuff, it would have been way harder, whereas now she can go online and she's able to meet people and it's really a huge factor. So this is some way sort of the positive side of technology isn't it, because it allows people who have minority interests, if you will, or sort of special interests not to be lonely forever, to actually find people who match their interests, match their needs,
这给我的生活增添了太多压力，我讨厌它。”然后你也可以看到另一面：“好吧，现在结婚的人中三分之一都是通过网上交友认识配偶的，其中很大一部分人遇到的人，如果不是因为这些网站，他们是根本不会相遇的。”所以你可以这样看：“哦，因为这项技术，世界上创造了海量的新的爱，如果没有这些东西，这种排山倒海般的爱根本就不会存在。”我觉得你无法否认这是一个积极的方面。
and this is what technology is enabled. It's really helped in those kind of end markets or whatever and I think that's a good point that for all these things I feel like one of the big questions a book is asking is, is all this stuff good or bad and I think for each thing it's not one answer, it's both, it really just depends on how you use these tools. Something like online dating, there's one notion of like, oh, everyone's on their phones, everyone thinks that there's something better out there,
这是喜剧演员阿齐兹·安萨里。他与社会学家埃里克·克莱嫩伯格合著的书是《现代情爱》。如果你喜欢这个节目，能帮我们一个忙吗？去iTunes给我们打个分。这能帮助其他人找到我们的节目。事实上，如果你在评论中随口说出“果酱”这个词，我们就会知道你是从这一期节目过来的。《隐藏的大脑》播客由卡拉姆·阿加尔·卡拉辛、玛吉·佩恩曼和马克斯·内斯特拉克制作，本周特别感谢达尼尔·舒钦和杰伊·西兹。想收听更多《隐藏的大脑》，请在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上找到我们，并在你当地的公共广播电台收听我的故事。
and it just added so much stress to my life and I hate it. Then you could also look at the other side of like, well, one out of three people that get married now, they meet their spouse through online dating and a huge percentage of these people are meeting people that they would not have met had it not been for these sites. So you could look at it like oh well there's an insane amount of new love in the world that's created because of this technology and there's this overwhelming amount of love that would not even be there had it not been for these things and I feel like you can't deny that that's a positive thing.
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔，这里是NPR。这个剧集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
That's comedian Aziz Ansari. His book written with the sociologist Eric Kleinenberg is Modern Romance. If you like this show, can you do us a favor, go to iTunes and give us a rating. This will help other people find our show. In fact, if you drop the word jam into your review, we'll know you came from this episode. The Hidden Brain podcast is produced by Karam Agar Kalasin, Maggie Penman and Max Nestrak, special thanks this week to Daniel Schuchin and Jay Siz. For more Hidden Brain, find us on Facebook, Twitter, and Instagram, and listen to my stories
那是喜剧演员阿齐兹·安萨里。他与社会学家埃里克·克莱嫩贝格合著的书是《现代情爱》。如果你喜欢这个节目，能帮个忙去iTunes给我们打个分吗？这将帮助其他人找到我们的节目。事实上，如果你在评论中写下“果酱”这个词，我们就知道你是从这一集过来的。“隐藏的大脑”播客由卡拉姆·阿加尔·卡拉辛、玛吉·彭曼和马克斯·内斯特拉克制作，本周特别感谢丹尼尔·舒钦和杰·西兹。想了解更多“隐藏的大脑”，请在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上关注我们，并收听我的故事
on your local public radio station. I'm Shankar Vitaantham, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在你的当地公共广播电台。我是尚卡尔·维塔安汉姆，这是NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。